what I'd like to do today is talk about
one of my favorite subjects and that is
the neuroscience of sleep now there is a
sound it works a sound that is desperate
that's what you're familiar to most of
us and of course it's the sound of the
alarm clock and what that truly ghastly
awful sound does is stop the single most
important behavioral experience that we
have and that's sleep if you're an
average sort of person 36 percent of
your life will be spent asleep which
means that if you live to 90 then 32
years 32 years will have been spent
entirely asleep
now what about 32 years is telling us
that sleep at some level is important
and yet for most of us we don't give
sleep a second thought we throw it away
we really just don't think about sleep
and so what I'd like to do today is
change your views change your ideas and
your thoughts about sleep and and the
journey that I want to take you on we
need to start by going back in time
enjoy the honey heavy dew of slumber any
ideas who said that Shakespeare's Julius
Caesar yes let me give you a few more
quotes Oh sleep oh gentle sleep
nature's soft nurse how thy freighted
thee Shakespeare again from I won't say
it the Scottish play
from the same time sleep is the golden
chain that ties health and our bodies
together extreme prophetic by Thomas
Dekker another Elizabethan dramatist but
if we jump forward 400 years the tone
about sleep changes somewhat this is
from thomas edison from the beginning of
the 20th century sleep is a criminal
waste of time and a heritage from our
cave days bang and if we also jump into
the 1980s some of you may remember that
Margaret Thatcher was reported to have
said sleep is for wimps
and of course the infamous what was his
name the infamous Gordon Gecko from Wall
Street said money Never Sleeps what do
we do in the 20th century about sleep
well of course we use Thomas Edison's
light bulb to invade the night and we
occupied the dark and in the process of
this occupation we've treated sleep as
an illness almost we treated as an enemy
an enemy but most now I suppose we think
of we tolerate the need for sleep and at
worst perhaps many of us think of sleep
as an illness that needs some sort of a
cure and our ignorant ignorance about
sleep is really quite profound why is it
why do we abandon asleep in our thoughts
well it's because you don't do anything
much while you're asleep it seems you
don't eat you don't drink and you don't
have sex well most of us anyway
um and so therefore it sorry it it's a
complete waste of time right wrong
actually sleep is an incredibly
important part of our biology and neuro
scientists are beginning to explain why
it's so very important so let's move to
the brain now here we have a brain
this is donated by a social scientist
and they said they didn't know what it
was indeed how to use it so
[Applause]
so I borrowed it I don't think they
noticed okay
the point I'm trying to make is that
when you're asleep
this thing doesn't shut down in fact
some areas of the brain are actually
more active during the sleep state than
during the wake state the other thing
that's really important about sleep is
that it doesn't arrive from a single
structure within the brain but is to
some extent a network property and if we
flip the brain on its back I love this
little bit of spinal cord here this bit
here is the hypothalamus and right under
there is a whole raft of interesting
structures not least the biological
clock the biological clock tells us when
it's good to be up when it's good to be
asleep and what that structure does is
interact with a whole raft of other
errors within the hypothalamus the
lateral hypothalamus the ventral lateral
preoptic nuclei all of those combined
and they send projections down to the
brainstem here the brainstem then
projects forward and bathes the cortex
this wonderfully wrinkly bit over here
with neurotransmitters that keep us
awake and essentially provide us with
our consciousness so sleep arises from a
whole raft of different interactions
within the brain and essentially sleep
is turned on and off as a result of a
range of interactions in here okay so
where we got to we've said that sleep is
complicated and it takes 32 years of our
of our life but what I haven't explained
is what sleep is about so why do we
sleep and it won't surprise any of you
that of course the scientists we don't
have a consensus there are dozens of
different ideas about why do you sleep
and I'm going to outline three of those
the first is sort of the restoration
idea and it's somewhat intuitive
essentially all the stuff we've burnt up
during the day we restore we replace we
rebuild during the night and indeed as
an explanation
it goes back to Aristotle so that's what
2,300 years ago it's gone in and out of
fashion it's fashionable at the moment
because what's been shown is that within
the brain a whole raft of genes have
been shown to be turned on only
during sleep and those genes are
associated with restoration and
metabolic pathways so there's good
evidence for the whole restoration
hypothesis what about energy
conservation again perhaps intuitive you
essentially sleep to save calories
now when you did the sums though it
doesn't really pan out if you compare an
individual who has slept at night or
stayed awake and hasn't moved very much
the energy-saving of sleeping is about
110 calories a night now that's the
equivalent of a hot dog bun now I would
say that hot dog bun is kind of a mega
return for such a complicated and
demanding behavior of sleep so I'm less
convinced by the the energy conservation
idea but the third idea I'm quite
attracted to which is brain processing
and memory consolidation what we know is
that if after you've tried to learn a
task and you sleep-deprived individuals
the ability to learn that task is
smashed it's it's really hugely
attenuated so the sleep and memory
consolidation is also very important
however it's not just the laying down a
memory and recalling it what's turned
out to be really exciting is that our
ability to come up with novel solutions
to complex problems is hugely enhanced
by night of sleep in fact it's been
estimated to give us a three-fold
advantage sleeping at night and enhances
our creativity and what seems to be
going on is that in the brain those
neural connections that are important
those synaptic connections that are
important are linked and strengthened
while those that are less important tend
to sort of fade away and be less
important okay so we've had three
explanations for why we might sleep and
I think the important thing to realize
is that the details will vary and it's
probably we sleep for multiple different
reasons but sleep is not an indulgence
it's not some sort of thing that we can
take on board rather casually I think
the sleepers once likened to an upgrade
from economy to business class you know
the equivalent of it's not it's not even
an upgrade from economy to
first class the critical thing to
realize is that if you don't sleep you
don't fly essentially you never get
there and what's extraordinary about
much of our society these days is that
we are desperately sleep-deprived so
let's now look at sleep deprivation huge
sectors of society are sleep deprived
and let's look at our sleep or matter so
in the 1950s good data suggests that
most of us were getting around about
eight hours of sleep a night
nowadays we sleep one and a half to two
hours less every night so we're in the
sort of six and a half hours every night
league for teenagers it's it's worse
much worse they need nine hours for full
brain performance and many of them on a
school night are only getting five hours
of sleep it's simply not enough if we
think about other sectors of society the
aged if you are aged then your ability
to sleep in a single block is somewhat
disrupted and many sleep again less than
five hours a night shift work shift work
is extraordinary perhaps 20% of the
working population and the body clock
does not shift with the demands of
working at night it's locked onto the
same light-dark cycle that the rest of
us so when the poor odd shift worker is
going home to try and sleep during the
day desperately tired the body clock is
saying wake up this is the time to be
awake so the quality of sleep that you
get as a nightshift work is usually very
poor again in that sort of five hour
region and then of course tens of
millions of people suffer from jetlag so
so who here has jetlag well my goodness
gracious well thank you very much indeed
for not falling asleep because that's
what your brain is craving one of the
things that the brain does is indulge in
microsleeps
this involuntary falling asleep and you
have essentially no control over it
now microsleeps can be sort of somewhat
embarrassing but they can also be deadly
it's been estimated that 31% of drivers
will fall asleep at the wheel at least
once in their life and in the US the
statistics are pretty good a hundred
thousand accidents on the freeway have
been associated with tiredness loss of
vigilance
and falling asleep hundred thousands of
years extraordinary at another level of
terror we dip into the tragic accidents
at Chernobyl and indeed the space
shuttle Challenger which were so
tragically lost and in the
investigations that followed those
disasters poor judgment as a result of
extended shift work and loss of
vigilance and tiredness was attributed
to a big chunk of of those those
disasters so when you're tired and you
lack sleep you have poor memory you have
poor creativity you have increased
impulsiveness and you have overall poor
judgment but my friends it's so much
worse than that
if you are a tired brain the brain is
craving things to make it up so drugs
stimulants caffeine represents the
stimulant of choice across much of the
Western world much of the day is fueled
by caffeine and if you're really naughty
tired brain nicotine and of course
you're fueling the waking state with
these stimulants and then of course it
gets through eleven o'clock at night and
the brain says to itself ah well
actually I need to be asleep fairly
shortly what do we do about that when
I'm feeling completely wired well of
course you then resort to alcohol and
now alcohol
short-term you know once or twice to use
this mildly sedate you can be very
useful it can actually ease the the
sleep transition but what you must be so
aware of is that alcohol doesn't provide
sleep a biological mimic for sleep it
sedates you so it actually harms some of
those neural processing that's going on
during memory consolidation and memory
recall so it's a short term acute
measure but for goodness sake don't
become addicted to alcohol as a way of
getting to sleep every night another
connection between loss loss of sleep is
weight gain if you sleep around about
five hours of less every night then you
have a 50% likelihood of being obese
what's the connection here well sleep
loss seems to give rise to the release
of the hormone ghrelin the hunger
hormone ghrelin is released it gets gets
to the brain the brain says I need
carbohydrates and what it does is seek
out
behide rates and particularly sugars so
there's our link between tiredness and
the metabolic predisposition for weight
gain stress tied people are massively
stressed and one of the things of stress
of course is loss of memory which is
what what I have just then had a little
hats off and and but stress is so much
more so if you're if you're acutely
stressed not a great problem but it's
sustained stress associated with sleep
loss that's the problem
so sustained stress leads us leads to
suppressed immunity and so tired people
tend to have higher rates of overall
infection and there's some very good
studies showing that shift workers for
example have higher rates of cancer
increased levels of stress through
glucose into the circulation glucose
becomes a dominant part of the
vasculature and essentially become
glucose intolerant
therefore diabetes to stress increases
cardiovascular disease as a result of
raising raising blood pressure so
there's a whole raft of things
associated with sleep loss that are more
than just a mildly impaired brain which
is where I think most people think that
sleep sleep loss resides so at this
point in the talk this is this is a nice
time to think well do you think on the
whole I'm getting enough sleep
um so quick show of hands who feels that
they're they're getting enough sleep
here
oh well that's pretty impressive good
we'll talk more about that later about
what your tips so most of us of course
asked the question well how do I know
whether I'm getting enough sleep well
it's not rocket science
if you need an alarm clock to get you
out of bed in the morning if you are
taking a long time to get up if you need
lots of stimulants if you're grumpy if
you're irritable if you're told by your
work colleagues that you're looking
tired and irritable chances are you are
sleep-deprived listen to them listen to
yourself
what do you do well this is slightly
offensive sleep for dummies
make your bedroom a haven for sleep the
first critical thing is make it as dark
as you possibly can and also make it
slightly cool very important actually
reduce your amount of light exposure at
least half an hour before you go to bed
light increases levels of alertness and
will delay sleep what's the last thing
that most of us do before we go to bed
we stand in a massively lit bathroom
with looking into the mirror cleaning
our teeth is the worst thing we could
possibly do to before we went to sleep
turn off those mobile phones turn off
those computers turn off all of those
things that are also going to it excite
the brain try not to drink caffeine too
late in the day ideally not after lunch
now we've said about reducing light
exposure before you go to bed but the
light exposure in the morning is very
good at setting the biological clock to
the light-dark cycle so seek out morning
light basically listen to yourself
wind down do those sorts of things that
you know are going to ease you off into
the into the honey heavy dew of slum
okay
that's some facts what about some myths
teenagers are lazy no poor things they
have a biological predisposition to go
to bed late and get up late so give them
a break we need eight hours of sleep a
night that's an average some people need
more some people eat need less and what
you need to do is listen to your body do
you need that much or do you need more
that simple as that old people need less
sleep not true the sleep demands of the
ages do not go down essentially sleep
fragments and becomes less robust but
sleep requirements do not go down and
the fourth myth is early to bed early to
rise makes a man healthy wealthy and
wise well that's wrong at so many
different levels
there is no no evidence that getting up
early and going to bed early gives you
more welfare at all there's no
difference in socioeconomic status in my
experience the only difference between
morning people and evening people is
that those people that get up in the
morning early I just horribly smug okay
so for the last part the last few
minutes what I want to do is change
gears and talk about some really new and
breaking errors of neuroscience which is
the association between mental health
mental illness and sleep disruption
we've known for a hundred and thirty
years that in severe mental illness
there is always always sleep disruption
but it's been largely ignored in the
1970s when people started to think about
this again they said yes well of course
you have sleep disruption in
schizophrenia because there are
antipsychotics it's the antipsychotics
causing the sleep problems ignoring the
fact that for a hundred years previously
sleep disruption had been reported
before antipsychotics so what's going on
lots of groups several groups are
studying conditions like depression
schizophrenia and bipolar and what's
going on in terms of sleep disruption we
have a big study which we published last
year on schizophrenia and the data were
quite extraordinary in those individuals
with schizophrenia much of the time they
were awake during the night phase and
then they're asleep during the day other
groups showed no 24-hour patters
whatsoever their sleep was absolutely
smashed and some had no ability to
regulate their sleep by the light dark
sake they were getting up later and
later and later and later each night it
was smashed so what's going on and the
really exciting news is that mental
illness and sleep are not simply
associated but they are physically
linked within the brain the neural
networks that predispose you to normal
sleep give you normal sleep and those
that give you normal mental health are
overlapping and what's the evidence for
that
well genes that have been shown to be
very important in the generation of
normal sleep when you take heed when
changed also pre
disposed individuals to mental health
problems and last year we published a
study which showed that a gene that's
been linked to schizophrenia which when
mutated also smashes the sleep so we
have evidence of a genuine mechanistic
overlap between these two important
systems other work flowed from these
studies the first was that sleep
disruption actually precedes certain
types of mental illness and we've shown
that in those young individuals who are
at high risk of developing bipolar
disorder they already have a sleep
abnormality prior to any clinical
diagnosis of bipolar the other bit of
data was that sleep consult sleep
disruption may actually exacerbate make
worse the the mental illness state my
colleague Dan Freeman has used the range
of agents which have stabilized sleep
and reduced levels of paranoia in those
individuals by 50% so what have we got
we've got in these connections some
really exciting things in terms of the
neuroscience by understand the
neuroscience of these two systems we're
really beginning to understand how both
sleep and little illness are generated
and regulated within the brain the
second area is that if we can use sleep
and sleep disruption as an early warning
signal then we have the chance of going
in if we know that these individuals are
vulnerable early intervention then
becomes possible and the third which I
think is the most exciting is that we
can think of the sleep centers within
the brain as a new therapeutic target
stabilized sleep in those individuals
who are vulnerable we can certainly make
them healthier but also alleviate some
of the appalling symptoms of mental
illness so let me just finish what I
started by saying is take sleep
seriously our attitudes towards sleep
are so very different from a
pre-industrial age when we were almost
wrapped in a duvet we used to understand
intuitively importance of sleep and this
isn't some sort of crystal waving
nonsense this is a pragmatic response to
good health if you have good sleep it
increases your concentration attention
decision-making creativity social skills
health if you get sleep
it reduces your mood changes your stress
your levels of anger your impulsivity
and your tendency to drink and take
drugs and we finished by saying that an
understanding of the neuroscience of
sleep is really informing the way we
think about some of the causes of mental
illness and indeed is providing us new
ways to treat these incredibly
debilitating conditions Jim Butcher the
fantasy writer said sleep is God go
worship and I can only recommend that
you do the same thank you for attention
[Applause]
[Music]